l'ukraine neutre sur le modèle
autrichien ou suédois la proposition
russe pour atteindre un compromis a été
balayée par kiev ce mercredi selon les
négociateurs ukrainiens le statut de
neutralité autrichien et suédois est
tout simplement inadapté un pays
attaqués par un autre
l'ukraine est maintenant en état de
guerre directe avec la russie par
conséquent le modèle ne peut être que
craignant
l'idée évoquée par moscou que l'ukraine
adopte une politique internationale sur
le modèle de l'autriche et de la suède
neutre et non-alignés envers les grandes
puissances
l'autriche est neutre depuis 1955 un
statut imposé par les soviétiques qui
occupait alors le pays avec les
occidentaux depuis la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale depuis vienne s'est
engagé à ne jamais adhérer à une
alliance militaire ni à accueillir de
bases militaires étrangères sur son
territoire
la suède elle les non-alignés en temps
de paix et vise la neutralité en temps
de guerre elle n'est pas membre de
l'alliance atlantique mais reste pour
autant un partenaire
néanmoins en tant que pays membre de
l'ue eux l'autriche et la suède peuvent
compter sur la solidarité des états
européens l'ukraine qui n'est pas membre
de l'union européenne ne veut pas
renoncer à ce que sa sécurité soit
garantie par des puissances étrangères
point de blocage pour moscou le
président ukrainien s'est néanmoins dit
prêt à ce que son pays renonce à
rejoindre l'otan
et depuis le